el terremoto político que tiene sobre esto
la victoria de la ultraderecha y en
Italia continúa durante Thor la cornada
de hoy ha seguido ocurriendo
numerosos rexios y hacia el mundo
cuando
esto es entrenamiento
extremistas un ejemplo son las Palabras
de Eduardo bolzonaro elico del
presidente
Brasileiro actualmente en el campo
elecciones en Brasil Edoardo Bolzonaro
celebró la victoria del líder
de hermanode Italia Giorgia Meloni
recordando y Lema Dios Patria y Familia
distinta a cambio del asilo la ración de
Gobierno de Gallo El primer ministro
franzisali lo que fransia velará parece
que si Empresa en el show derechos
actividades de civilis en Italia
eneste concurso la primera victima
de la cornada electoral del domingo al
logro ser y líder progresista
Enrico Letta que si el café de la Fiesta
Demócrata que da esta paiselletta tiene
informado que no evolucionará para repetir e
en la Carga y quien se comunicará y permanecerá
decisión y en el próximo congreso que
celebrar el entrenamiento